this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday January 27th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
despite the Litany of ways scammers have
found to Target people online in the U.S
phone calls Remain the primary way
swindler's hook older victims calls like
this one that the Federal Trade
Commission shared with us we found that
there was a fraud and misconduct on your
tax which you are hiding from the
federal government this need to be
rectified immediately so do return the
call as soon as you receive the message
that may sound a bit robotic but those
calls and other more lifelike ones are
catching people out there are ways
though that Tech can prevent you and
your loved ones from falling for or even
getting these calls with me to discuss
that is our family and Tech columnist
Julie jargon hi Julie thanks for joining
me hi thank you for having me so how big
a deal are scam calls
they're a pretty big deal especially
among older adults a study published
last month by the Federal Trade
Commission found that 24 percent of
adults over the age of 60 who reported
losing money to a scam in 2021 said it
started with a phone call
and for even older adults that
percentage is even greater for people 80
and older phone calls were behind 40
percent of scams that were reported
so I'm sure some of us can imagine how
these scams might work but can you give
us an example of what's being said to
lure people into these scams yeah
scammers use a variety of methods there
are Robo calls with a recorded message
that comes on when you answer saying
that they're from the IRS and they're
trying to collect a late tax payment we
have just received a notification
regarding your tax filings then there
are individuals who call people and try
to pose as someone's grandchild saying
that they were wrongfully arrested did
they need money in order to get out of
jail and then there are people that call
and ask you to get them a gift card
saying that they need the money from a
gift card for some reason okay so let's
talk about some of the ways to avoid
these scams then should we just be
blocking phone numbers that's one way to
do it of course that's not always
feasible especially if you are you know
awaiting an important phone call from
your doctor's office or your health care
company or your child's school maybe
those phone numbers aren't saved in your
phone's contacts list and so you don't
want to miss an important call but you
can screen on your own and let important
calls go to voicemail scammers typically
aren't going to leave a voice message
okay so is there anything then that you
can put on your phone to stop these
calls from coming in in the first place
yeah there are a number of different
things that you can do so if you have a
Google pixel phone for example you can
have Google Assistant screen your calls
for you so if a call comes in from an
unknown caller the assistant determines
whether the call is Spam and if it is
your phone just hangs up on the caller
otherwise it will send the call through
to you
there's also a new service that's being
developed by an online safety company
called Aura which has also developed a
bot to catch calls both on iPhones and
Android phones before they get to the
recipient that new feature is expected
to be available through the Aura app in
the next few months and it works in the
same type of way if a call comes in from
a number that is not in the recipient's
contacts list the artificial
intelligence answers the phone call asks
the caller's name and reason for calling
and using that information along with
the caller's phone number the AI can
determine whether the call is legitimate
and whether to send it through but there
are also things that you can do on your
your phone itself on your actual device
so for example if you have an iPhone and
it's running a fairly recent operating
system you can silence unknown callers
there's a phone setting that allows you
to do that if you do notice any of these
should you be reporting these scams
somewhere you can report calls to the
FTC however I'm sure they get overloaded
with reports like this so it may not
result in anything being done
immediately you know but the main thing
is to just not engage so if you pick up
a call especially if it's a robocall
that prompts you to hit a button don't
do that don't opt to speak to a live
operator that's probably going to take
you to someone who's going to start
asking you for personal information so
it's best if you don't know the person
and if it seems a bit suspicious to just
hang up
sometimes I'll see on my phone the words
scam call or suspected scam call coming
up are the carriers doing enough to
label these calls when they come in to
suggest to people that they shouldn't
answer them
I mean there's certainly a lot of people
who feel like the carriers are not doing
enough because these calls do come
through personally I have an 847 area
code from having previously lived in the
Chicago area I now live in LA but I
still have this number and I get several
calls a day coming from 847 area codes
and I do not answer them and the college
never leave messages so they're not
legitimate calls in 2019 AARP did a
survey and found that 59 percent of
respondents said they're more likely to
answer the phone if a number has their
area code so obviously scammers have you
know realized this and that's why
they're spoofing caller ID to make it
appear that their calls are coming from
your area code because you see that and
you think well maybe that's my doctor's
office or maybe that's some other place
that you know nearby that needs to reach
me for some reason
do we expect to see this kind of scam
fade over time as maybe less people pick
up their phones or stop you know
trusting phone calls that are coming in
I think that's the hope and that's the
point of this technology is that that
will clamp down on on these kind of spam
calls and scam calls but people are
still picking up the phone so it's still
happening it's still a major problem but
yeah if people stop answering their
phone the scammers will find another way
and they are finding other ways to reach
victims there's text scams and email
scams and social media scams so there's
multiple ways that scammers will you
know look to the next place to go to
find people
a little game of whack-a-mole I suppose
that's our family and Tech columnist
Julie jargon Julie thanks for joining us
thank you for having me
and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week tnb's producer is Julie Chang
our supervising producer is Melanie Roy
and our executive producer is Chris
sinsley I'm your host Zoe Thomas thanks
for listening and have a great weekend
[Music]